salut à vous peuple et d internet vous
souvenez qu'il ya quelque temps j'ai
fait une vidéo avec le nook qui habitent
ou envoyer dans les deux sens et je vous
apprenait à mélanger un jeu de cartes à
l'américaine j'espère que maintenant
c'est bon et vous avez le mélange est
bien aujourd'hui je re film encore avec
ce téléphone j'avais dit que je referai
des vidéos avec mais il ya un petit
changement par rapport à la dernière
fois c'est que cette vidéo est en
partenariat avec nokia qui m'ont
contacté suite à la première vidéo et ça
ça fait plaisir parce qu'en plus ça
permettra de mettre en place d'autres
projets donc cette vidéo est aussi
réalisée avec le nokia n8 dual sight
mode c'est à dire que je vais filmer
l'arrière et l'avant en même temps c'est
pas au montage que je vais rajouter les
deux sources mais vraiment film et en
simultané est une des vidéos que je vous
annonçais et c'est ce que je vais faire
du coup je me suis dit si ça génial
c'est de filmer les micro-expressions de
quelqu'un des détails et en même temps
tout en pouvant me filmer - en même
temps c'est ce qu'on va faire dans
quelques secondes avec les cette micro
expressions majeures dont on a déjà
parlé sur la chaîne et pour terminer le
côté un petit peu informatif le
téléphone peut aussi prendre les photos
des deux côtés en même temps c'est pas
forcément que des vidéos
je vous mets un lien dans la description
vous en saurez beaucoup plus pourquoi de
cette petite étude sur les
micro-expressions évidemment vous l'avez
déjà vous la voyez ici là maintenant
tout de suite j'ai demandé à céline h de
ne rejoindre merci beaucoup s'est levé
et alors est ce que tu sais pourquoi
j'ai fait appel à toi précisément parce
que ce serait parce que je suis
comédienne
oui car si vous n'avez pas vu l'une des
dernières vidéo on est aussi avec cyril
super connard tu nous avait démontré des
talents de comédie en surtout sur le jeu
de la tristesse qui je crois a bluffé
tout le monde puisque tu t'étais mise
quand même à pleurer sur commande avec
une pratique qui disait je prépare un
boeuf bourguignon mais ça aujourd'hui
harry n'a pleuré sur je prépare un boeuf
bourguignon je crois que tu veut tous
jouer dans ta vie que tu nous expliquer
cette fois là qu'en fait tu étais allé
chercher une émotion réelle de quelque
chose qui était arrivé pour pouvoir
jouer ça c'est ça c'est une des méthodes
possibles on peut aller chercher une
vraie tristesse dans son vécu et
ressentir à nouveau pour pouvoir le
régurgiter dans son jeu donc il ya cette
micro expressions majeures je sais que
tu en connais une partie joie colère
tristesse des goûts adam est primé pris
peur peur et surprise surprise
exactement je vous invite à regarder
l'une des anciennes vidéos où on en
parle beaucoup plus ce qui m'intéresse
aujourd'hui grâce au mode websites
edinho qui a huit ses devoirs en même
temps des réactions et moi que je puisse
les commenter tu vois oui je vois enfin
je vois rien moi
toi tu vois rien parce que l'écran de
mon côté forcément je te demander comme
toi tu es une bonne comédienne et que tu
as accès à tes anciennes émotions
d'essayer de les revivre
et on va voir ce qui se passe sur ton
visage je vais le voir vous allez le
voir et ça c'est cool on va s'en faire
la moitié aujourd'hui des
micro-expressions c'est à dire 3 3 et
demi des fois quand je vous avais
l'impression que je regarde au dessus
c'est parce que je la regarde elle
je vous rappelle qu'en fait nous sommes
des deux côtés mais en même temps à ma
main on commence par la peur je te
propose de faire la part leur cherche
pas à bien faire ou a mal faire des
choses justes et c'est d'avoir un
sentiment un souvenir où tu avais peur
et essaye de le vivre
mais moi je vais te regarder sur l'écran
parce que c'est pas facile la peur c'est
pas simple mais c'est pas nous c'est pas
le plus rarement très peur dans cette
voie alors j'essaye
ok c'est hyper intéressant ce qui se
passe ok c'est pas mal ce qui est en
train de se passer vous voyez la bouche
qui s'ouvre légèrement c'est un signe de
peur en micro expressions
ok tu peux t'arrêter mais ce qui était
très intéressant c'est que on a vu en
fait des yeux s'ouvrirent un petit peu
plus pas beaucoup plus longtemps que
d'habitude mais un peu plus quand même
la bouche qui s'est légèrement ouverte
et légèrement les sourcils qui sont
rapprochés mais c'était très très léger
et ça ça devenait une expression de peur
est normal et une micro expressions ça
ne passe que furtivement 0,25 seconde
c'est hyper rapide tu vois mais les
quatre points majeurs et on les a
quasiment tous retrouvés là sur toi
c'est effectivement ça c'est assez
génial c'est la bouche qui s'ouvre le de
muscles des paupières qui se lève en
fait les yeux qui s'écarquillent un
petit peu comme on dit des sorties qui
monte qui se rapprochent l'un de l'autre
et la public qui se rétracte là on l'a
pas du tout lu mais c'est normal puisque
tu ne vivait pas de peur instantanée et
ça c'est dans l'instant dans le présent
mais n'oublions pas qu'une micro
expressions c'est toujours furtif se
passe en un quart de seconde c'est
vraiment le principe quand ça dure plus
longtemps c'est une expression est une
micro expressions ne peut pas être
simulés mais une expression peut être
simulé
on en a la preuve quand on a une bonne
comédienne salut bonjour enchanté je
suis de l'autre côté de la caméra un
numéro 2 je te propose de choisir la
colère colère raille parti pour la
colère alors il ya quatre points majeurs
dans la colère je te dit pas lesquels
évidemment mais il ya quatre points
majeurs
parce que si j'en ai aucun juif à bonn
c'est vrai alors je pars en colère du
tout bernard tu arrives pas tous les
maux mais de monsieur b colère ok on en
a 1,2
on en a deux quelques sur les 4 mais
c'est pas mal parce qu on l'a si on
regarde on sait que tu es en colère en
tout cas il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
les quatre points de la colère je te le
dis tu l'avais très bien ici c'est
l'élève qui se passe des choses qu'on
fait spontanément en micro expressions
de colère les narines qui se dilate
l'avait également le regard qui restent
fixes lui je le compte parce que tu
regarde droit devant toi mais tu vas le
faire à chaque à chaque fois là pour
cette vidéo c'est plus logique mais
c'est le regarde qui restent fixes sur
sa cible et le dernier que tu avais
moins que les autres c'est les sourcils
qui comme on dit qui feront sa beauté
proches et qui a à ses bonnes nouvelles
sont figés babillage surjouer j'avais dû
c'est pas mal je pensais pas que ça
marcherait aussi bien en fait je pensais
que c'est juste aurait le regard un peu
noir mais c'est hyper intéressant de
voir que tu met en action ce qu'on
appelle les unités d'actions les bonnes
unités d'actions à chaque fois je le
répète parce que je le pressens dans les
commentaires non on ne peut pas simuler
une pro expression parce qu'elle est
trop furtive trop rapide on peut pas
réfléchir à faire quelque chose de si
court qu'un quart de seconde issue à ce
que veut dire oui moi en tout cas je
vois toi tu vois vous voyez vous pour le
troisième c'est final je te propose
d'essayer de me stimuler l'expression du
mépris le mépris moi il ya trois points
majeurs dans le métro oui bien un deux
trois j'en ai 3 tu peux arrêter cette
réel malaise en maintenant vous
bénéficiez encore des travaux qui a
toujours dans la rue d'avis que les
travaux en arrivant ils sont dehors
mais ils sont là la pète c'est magique
mais il tape chez toi demande du café
mais ça donc c'est d'eux dont plus
compliqué de se concentrer sans être
perturbés par les personnes les trois
points principaux du mépris on les avait
à savoir
la tête qui se relève voilà exactement
exactement ça le menton aussi qui se
redresse un peu indépendamment de la
tête et c'est la seule micro expressions
qui est asymétrique sait déjà qu'on a le
muscle des zygomatiques qui va faire
remonter les lèvres mais que d'un seul
côté
est ce que tu peux essayer de nous
refaire une petite asymétrie exactement
là le mouvement qu'on a vu c'est
exactement ça tu avais une bonne unité
d'action au bon moment bravo selina lo
les vidéos abo j'ai dit non
mais personne n'applaudit pas parce
qu'on ne tourne pas en public pourtant
fait un quatrième et un dernier pour
cette vidéo vous ferait le reste dans
une autre vidéo si ça tu vas tu es ce
que tu veux faire parmi ces responsables
pasteur n'a pas fait une fois la
surprise on n'apprenait pas fait la
surprise même dégoût non prévenus on n'a
pas fait la joie la surprise bon allez
les premiers surprise à marseille le
surprise ces trois unités d'actions est
ce que j'ai donné comme ça alors
attention surprise pas mal est ce que tu
peux repasser envisage natale refaire
ouais c'est bien mais alors ça je pense
que c'est parce que on ne vit pas une
micro expressions les retailles les deux
principaux à savoir les sourcils qui se
relève et la bouche qui s'ouvre c'est
pas qu'elle s'en trouve pas comme dans
la peur elle s'ouvre vraiment par contre
en temps normal on a les yeux qui sert
clerc qui beaucoup plus que ce que tu as
eu à redire c'est vraiment ça dépendra
surprises ont en tout cas au point de
générer une micro expressions de
surprise on a un vrai car kim endurant
encore une fois un quart de seconde je
le dis souvent mais c'est important
c'est très furtif
là on l'a eue très légèrement beaucoup
moins mais parce que tu me dis si je me
trompe je ne pense pas que tu viennes
d'accéder à un vrai souvenir passé je
pense que tu as juste voulu simuler la
surprise ouais moi puis une surprise
c'est large une surprise c'est
surprenant et là on n'est pas du tout
dans le jeu mais très sains je pense que
j'ai fait un imprimé un cadre pour toi
une surprise c'est sur koné long métrage
2010 sera encore plus plus plus complexe
tu viens d'avoir un million d'abonnés tu
vois mais même quand même on voit que
dans la simulation je suis en train de
m'en rendre compte avec toi en temps
réel on n'a pas autant d'écart qui
manquent on aurait effectivement mais
est-ce que ça dépend pas des yeux des
gens non non non non je disais que
c'était le botox tu as avec complexe en
jette une blague a bien entendu juifs
aboiteaux que c'est par contre c'est
marrant de voir là on le constate encore
plus avec toi grâce à toi que les liens
qui entre la surprise et la peur tu veux
on a une ouverture de la bouche c'est
pas la même on a aussi les sourcils qui
se lève mais pas autant way et on a
aussi un mouvement au niveau des quarts
qui ment des yeux mais c'est pas tout à
fait les mêmes jeux pasteur d'or
surprise
bref vas-y tiré par trois petites
démission perdre une prise vidéo un
fantôme père surprise geek en fait y
avait aussi la joie d'avoir peur avec le
dégoût de la surprise
hyper complexe comme micro expressions
c'était pas une telenovela c'était la
vignette en fait cette vidéo on s'arrête
là c'est déjà pas mal pour réviser un
peu ces micro expressions
reprendre aussi l'habitude de les
observer j'en ai beaucoup parlé sur la
chaîne d'ailleurs je vous met la vidéo
en eau et dans la description vous
pourrez revoir mais là vous pourrez
aussi comparer avec les les endroits
dont je parle
il se mettait vraiment en action sur toi
t'es cool ça fait une bonne des baux un
bon exemple
je suis un petit peu la tête coiffante
pour les est coiffeuse qui sont très
bons bah moi je serai votre visage pour
vous entraîner sur les mises des
cessions déjà j'ai essayé de le dire
correctement
il croit que ce paquet d'histoires que
je joue mieux que ce que je prends vous
commettez une timité gainsbourg ces
chercheurs
comme je vous l'aï dit au début de vidéo
et dans la précédente vidéo je compte
faire d'autres vidéos avec ce téléphone
partenariat le pas mais du coup merci à
nokia pour celle ci je vous mets un lien
vers tout ce téléphone est la
description est tous dans la description
jeu mais également la chaîne de la
description a aussi frôlé une idée et
frôle les 10 mille abonnés je suis pas
loin les gars allez je suis bientôt et
ladiville abonnés et oui un petit projet
ou youtube space que vous découvrirez
plus tard sur sa chaîne après la
surprise c'est encore mieux
merci à vous n'hésitez pas à liker la
vidéo si elle vous a plu vous pouvez
aussi donner des idées dans les
commentaires de vidéos que vous aimeriez
faire avec ce mode là le dual sight mode
ça peut être saisie des blogs de choses
comme ça quoi qu'il arrive il y aura une
vidéo suivante on terminera les
micro-expressions ensemble et tu sais ce
que c'est en train de me faire penser
j'ai tellement envie que tu traduisent
en langage des signes ce que je dis pas
ce que la sur l'écran ça marche pas trop
bien mais je sais pas faire ça et du
coup on ne le fera pas à très bientôt
peuplé d internet ciao
[Musique]